más de 250 millones de personas viven en
un país distinto al que nacieron es
decir que son inmigrantes y ojo amigos
porque este número no para de crecer
[Música]
en los últimos 50 años se ha
multiplicado por tres y tan solo desde
el año 2000 el número de inmigrantes se
ha incrementado atentos en 80 millones
80 millones de personas que se han
marchado de su país en busca de una vida
mejor
y tal y como os podéis imaginar la
mayoría de todos los inmigrantes que hay
en el mundo más del 65% se han
establecido en los países más ricos en
países como eeuu alemania australia o
canadá
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y esto es precisamente queridos amigos
de visual política el motivo que está
alimentando a lo largo y ancho del mundo
controvertidos furiosos y encarnizados
debates sobre la inmigración y también
el discurso de muchos movimientos
populistas
en los últimos años sin ir más lejos en
europa por ejemplo estamos viendo cómo
están surgiendo un montonazo de partidos
populistas y xenófobos que han puesto a
la inmigración directamente en la diana
que si nos roban el trabajo que si nos
ponen en peligro que si destruyen
nuestra identidad nacional etcétera
etcétera pero tal vez con todo el caso
con diferencia más importante es el de
donald trump un presidente que ha dejado
claro muy claro que la inmigración no le
gusta absolutamente nada salvo al
parecer alguna que otra excepción fijaos
según medios locales como el washington
post y el new york times' trump dijo que
eeuu no debería recibir inmigrantes de
países de como el salvador o las
naciones africanas sino de noruega por
qué diantres pensar a trump que los
noruegos quieren emigrar masivamente a
eeuu cuando ya son más ricos que los
norteamericanos pero no nos desviemos
amigos es realmente la inmigración un
peligro una carga un lastre están los
eeuu perdiendo empuje económico por
culpa de todos los inmigrantes que hay
en el país tienen acaso los eeuu que
frenar la llegada de más extranjeros
pues bien veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si en algo vamos a estar todos de
acuerdo es que vivimos en un mundo que
cada día está más interconectado es
decir donde cada vez resulta más fácil
más rápido y más barato ir de un sitio a
otro
[Música]
y donde también cada vez es más fácil
contactar con nuestros seres queridos
sin importar el lugar donde nos
encontremos y como os podéis imaginar
todas estas son cosas que hacen que
tomar la decisión de hacer las maletas y
marcharse a otro país sea mucho pero que
mucho más fácil por eso si en los años
60 habían 90 millones de inmigrantes en
todo el mundo hoy ya son más de 250
millones
y sabéis que podemos esperar que este
número crezca con fuerza en los próximos
años primero porque cada vez es más
fácil moverse y segundo por el enorme
crecimiento demográfico que están
experimentando muchos países pobres así
que amigos la pregunta es hay motivos
para preocuparse atentos
[Música]
un golpe de suerte
cada vez que en los países ricos se
habla sobre inmigración parece que se
está debatiendo sobre si hacer o no una
especie de obra de caridad y sabéis que
nada más lejos de la realidad
la emigración favorece el crecimiento
económico entre otras cosas porque la
mayoría de los inmigrantes son personas
adultas en edad de trabajar fijaos se
calcula que desde el año 2000 los
inmigrantes han sido responsables ojo de
entre el 40 y el 80 por ciento del
crecimiento de la fuerza laboral en los
principales países receptores
vamos que sin ellos estos países serían
bastante menos ricos pero amigos sí lo
sé cómo todo esto es bastante abstracto
si os parece podemos fijarnos en lo que
ha ocurrido precisamente en uno de los
países donde últimamente más
controversia ha generado todo esto de la
inmigración el reino unido
pues bien durante los últimos años
mientras algunos grupos políticos
alertaban sobre la enorme amenaza que la
inmigración incluida ojo la procedente
de otros países de la unión europea
suponía para los empleos británicos para
su identidad para su modo de vida lo
cierto es que la economía ha puesto
sobre la mesa números muy pero que muy
diferentes
nunca antes en la historia tantas
personas habían tenido un empleo en
reino unido como en nuestros días ni en
términos absolutos ni tampoco en
términos relativos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no importa si excluimos a los
inmigrantes nunca antes nunca antes la
población de origen británico había
tenido tantas oportunidades laborales
como ahora y no sólo eso según los
estudios de varias universidades
británicas todos estos inmigrantes pagan
más impuestos de lo que obtienen del
estado y por si todo esto no fuera
suficiente reino unido- está logrando
atraer el mayor número de inmigrantes
universitarios de cualquier país europeo
es decir en otras palabras que el efecto
de esta inmigración está siendo muy pero
que muy positivo para los propios
británicos y además está contribuyendo a
convertir a reino unido en toda una
potencia tecnológica no está mal verdad
pues sabéis que a pesar de los
encendidos discursos de trump lo cierto
es que en el otro lado del atlántico las
cosas no son nada pero que nada
diferentes atentos el sueño
norteamericano con algo más de 44
millones de personas más o menos la
población de españa eeuu es en términos
absolutos el país con más inmigrantes de
todo el mundo
[Música]
sin embargo he esperado un momento
porque en términos relativos la cosa
cambia estas 44 millones de personas
suponen algo menos del 14 por ciento de
toda la población para que os hagáis una
idea en países como australia o nueva
zelanda por ejemplo el porcentaje es
casi el doble
[Música]
ahora bien os hago una pregunta y no
vale mirar para otro lado qué impacto
pensáis que tienen los inmigrantes en
eeuu pues amigos prestad atención a
pesar de representar algo menos del 14
por ciento de la población los
inmigrantes son responsables de casi el
25 por ciento de todos los negocios que
se abren en eeuu de más del 30 por
ciento de las empresas en que invierten
los fondos de capital-riesgo y de
prácticamente la mitad de todas las
startups de alta tecnología de silicon
valley y ahí no acaba todo según un
estudio del centro para el
emprendimiento el 43% de las 500 mayores
empresas de eeuu fueron fundadas bien
por inmigrantes o bien por hijos de
inmigrantes
y esa es la que yo sigo uib ordenado
fuerte teniendo price casting victoria
[Música]
tú
116 empresas cuyos ingresos superan cada
año los 5 billones de dólares y dan
empleo a casi tg millones de personas en
todo el mundo
[Música]
hablamos ni más ni menos que del gran
poder económico de los eeuu amigos desde
henri ford y lo más muchas de las
grandes figuras de los personajes
icónicos de los estados unidos ni
siquiera nacieron en este país
[Música]
pero un momento puede que alguno de
vosotros esté pensando vale vale alberto
esto es cosa sólo de unos pocos
inmigrantes de los más preparados pero
qué pasa con el resto pues la verdad
los números no son muy diferentes sus
tasas de emprendimiento y empleo son
también muy altas y además aportan otros
muchos beneficios por ejemplo en un país
que en este momento no lo olvidemos se
encuentra en pleno empleo los nuevos
inmigrantes refuerzan la competitividad
de eeuu y permiten poner en marcha
muchos negocios que de otra forma no se
hubieran creado
es decir resumiendo los inmigrantes
reducen la edad media de la población
tienen más hijos investigan más son más
emprendedores logran más patentes
etcétera etcétera pues bien a pesar de
los contundentes que son los datos y de
que nunca antes en la historia tantos
estadounidenses habían tenido un empleo
a políticos como donald trump todo esto
de la inmigración sigue sin gustarles
nada claro que sabéis que no es la
primera vez que en eeuu los líderes
políticos tienen un discurso contra la
inmigración atentos
e
[Música]
los precedentes amigos no es ni mucho
menos la primera vez que los eeuu el
país de los inmigrantes se desatan
campañas políticas contra la inmigración
fijaos ya por mediados del siglo 19 el
movimiento político no aún afín se opuso
a los inmigrantes particularmente a los
irlandeses y poco después le tocó el
turno a los chinos si habéis escuchado
bien a los chinos
durante la segunda mitad del siglo 19
fueron muchos los chinos que llegaron a
eeuu y eso desencadenó una reacción
popular bastante pero que bastante
hostil desde seattle hasta los ángeles
desde wyoming hasta los pequeños pueblos
de california los inmigrantes chinos
fueron obligados a dejar negocios a
abandonar ciudades fueron golpeados
torturados linchados y masacrados
generalmente con la mínima esperanza de
recibir ayuda de la ley inmigración obra
de la biblioteca del congreso de los
eeuu todo esto porque básicamente en
aquel momento los norteamericanos
consideraban a los chinos competencia
el caso es que en 1882 el propio
congreso federal aprobó la ley de
exclusión de los chinos que no sólo
suspendió la llegada de nuevos
inmigrantes chinos sino que además a los
que ya estaban en eeuu les hizo la vida
bastante complicada y aquí no acaba todo
en 1924 después de que alrededor de 30
millones de personas atravesarán el
océano atlántico para llegar a los eeuu
washington estableció una política de
cuotas que reducía fuertemente el número
de inmigrantes que podían llegar y
además vetaba de facto a los inmigrantes
procedentes del sur de europa como
españa del este de europa de asia y de
áfrica vamos que los pocos que podían
entrar tenían que ser básicamente
anglosajones
[Música]
y más recientemente en 1994 el entonces
gobernador de california wilson
culpó a los inmigrantes hispanos de la
mala situación económica por la que
atravesaba el estado y sabéis que hizo
pues lanzó una campaña política contra
la inmigración e impulsó la conocida
como proposición 187 una ley que impedía
el acceso a los servicios sociales
educativos e incluso sanitarios para
todos los inmigrantes en situación
irregular incluso los niños era tan
agresiva que apenas un año más tarde el
tribunal supremo la declaró
inconstitucional
[Aplausos]
diamond hizo the state
[Música]
con todos los datos en la mano creo
sinceramente que tanto en la casa blanca
como en el capitolio deberían estar
pensando no en deportar a gente o en
endurecer el sistema de acceso sino en
cómo aprobar de una vez por todas una
reforma migratoria que realmente
facilite la llegada ordenada de más
personas más trabajadores más
emprendedores y más investigadores para
la gran economía norteamericana por
cierto en un próximo vídeo que
intentaremos este muy pronto disponible
en nuestra página de patrón y más tarde
aquí en el canal hablaremos
uno a uno de los grandes mitos que
existen sobre la inmigración pero ahora
turno para ti crees que tu país debe
reducir la entrada de inmigrantes
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta y como
siempre si te ha resultado interesante
este vídeo darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a visual polític si aún no lo
has hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
wow
en el relax una opción r brand server
[Música]